[Music]
ever since the split from Angelina Brad
Pitt has been totally camera shy about
doing interviews we've seen him on red
carpets keeping his lips sealed but now
finally Brad is getting candid in front
of the lens about his new life it's not
so difficult to achieve a balance I'm
able to compartmentalize pretty well the
private life the public life fortunately
I guess we were able to survive our
mistakes along the way Brad gave his
first TV sit-down since his split
speaking to CNN 18 in India he didn't
mention the kids but Brad did make a
casual reference to Angelina saying the
last time he was in the country they
were together we actually shot a mighty
heart here I got to scoot around just
get out amongst the masses it was really
nice what's the secret to staying
relevant I see a little bit of luck I
trying to reinvent make sure you get
time for yourself time for your friends
time for your family the 53 year olds
been all smiles traveling the world
promoting his Netflix film war machine
so what's Brad strategy for making a
comeback after scandal one word charm I
see you the point the wave that smile
working the crowd and being funny do you
believe in life after death
I definitely believe in death after life
Brad did the comedy bit with Colbert he
did the distract them with weird fashion
thing wearing those grandpa pants and he
did the vulnerable confess all interview
with GQ admitting I was boozing too much
and I just started therapy but the one
the tops of all this prom pose with Gina
Rodriguez I Pig yeah honey yeah squeeze
when I was talking to my boyfriend about
it he was like it's like you met the
male Beyonce and I was like thank you so
does that make him the king bee whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
you